don't say a word me and Jade's boyfriend
isn't always easy now is it BEC
she's got a big personality and she
isn't afraid to use it while some people
see her as a fiercely dark humor person
deep down you know she has a heart of
gold Jade would do anything for you back
a little too much for you ask us but hey
we wouldn't want to get on your
girlfriend's bad side Jade west is a
savage and Tori Vega can attest to that
but despite all of her shortcomings jade
is hilarious and victorious wouldn't
have been the same without her we've
lined up all of Jade's most savage
moments keep watching to find out which
one of these moments could have landed
Jade in jail Jade dumps back in season 1
episode 5 Jade decides to break things
off with BEC when she finds out that
she's been hanging out and texting
Alyssa Vaughn she's super jealous and
she doesn't trust him but even then she
wants him back Tory goes out of her way
to help Jade when her boyfriend back and
she encourages her to do something nice
for him like get him that dog he always
wanted
once they patched things up Tori asks
Jade for a ride home and Jade being the
Savage she is tells her that it's not
that far along yep the girl is merciless
Tori and Jade's play dates in season 3
episode 6 Tori and Jade are selected to
play a married couple in a new play but
sicka wits isn't too happy with how Jade
and Tori are getting along so he forces
them to go out on a date during the
state Tori points out that there's no
good reason that they can't sit down and
have a conversation and that's when Jade
strikes
she tells Tori that there's a good
reason and then says I don't like you
ouch that one must have left a mark the
wood in season 1 episode 18 a reality
show called the wood sets up shop at
Hollywood Arts and the students are
interviewed to win a spot on the show
Jade doesn't hold back when the
producers ask her to name some of the
things that she hates she goes off on a
rant saying that she hates things like
flowers giggling rainbows and the color
yellow and most of all jokes
man I hate ducks it's a hilarious moment
that ultimately wins her a spot on the
show opposite date we all know Jade is a
jealous girlfriend but she took things
to a whole new level in season
or episode 3 in the episode titled
opposite date cat accidentally tells
Jade about how BEC and Tori are on what
they are calling an opposite date Jade
flips out and proceeds to stock them by
impersonating cat on the phone it's a
hilarious moment but Jade goes full
savage when she tricks cat into putting
her head on her shoulder only to
restrain her cover her mouth and steal
her phone the gorilla Club in season 3
episode 4 Jaden Beck get into another
fight Beck points out that he's tired of
all the fighting prompting Jade to ask
him if he wants to break up and that's
when Trina jumps in and tries to make a
move on beg Jay fires back immediately
she throws a pillow at her face and
warns her that next time it's a hammer
Helen back again in season 2 episode 8
Jade goes ballistic during a school
announcement when Sikowitz is having a
hard time getting the student boy to
listen to his speech Jade stands up and
quiets everyone down by screaming it's a
hilarious moment that just goes to show
how intimidating Jade can be sicko it's
fires back by calling Jade sweet and
feminine brain squeezers it's no secret
that jade has a bone to pick with Tori
and this is showcased once again in
season 4 episode 10 when Tori asks Jade
for a fry instead of giving her one Jade
spits all over them and Tori forgets all
about Jade's fries but Sinden doesn't
Jade warns him expect lows but he
chooses to eat one anyway opposite date
part 2 there are a lot of savage moments
in the episode titled opposite date like
the time that Jade asks Tori if she's
wearing a new top and then says thanks
when she says that she is while Jade can
come off as a bully there's a method to
her madness
and besides Tori is no angel the birth
week song in season 1 episode 4 jage
plays a prank on Tori and it's a pretty
gross one she asked story to try our
coffee and tell her what it tastes like
only to laugh and tell her I don't know
I found it in the garbage
then when Trina refers to Jade as Tory's
friend Jade walks off saying that she
isn't her friend who was it just us or
his date on a roll
get stuck this savage Jade moment should
have landed her in gel in season 2
episode 4 Jade gets cast as Tori's
understudy
so she plots against her when Tori
donates her blood to save Robbie Jade
gets rid of the first pint forcing Tori
to miss the play here are the things we
post daily videos about nostalgic shows
like victorious so make sure to
subscribe if you're watching on your
mobile go into your YouTube settings and
switch on notifications so you never
miss another video clearly Jade is one
wicked character but we love her all the
same
who was your favorite character from
Victorious sound off in the comments
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things we'll see you
next time